true pot head will smoke anywhere
anytime and out of anything
I'm gonna get you high pop bass that's a
good way to get blazed and get your
omega-3s
I love fish so much I turned our office
into an aquarium
[Music]
it isn't hear that music you every fish
for himself
like we'd shark-fin soup tonight boys
good shot that was just an excuse to buy
those radio-controlled fish you don't
really keep your staff on their toes a
harpoon gun are you sure he stole it
maybe you just put it behind a plant
when you were high and forgot about it
kids you're gonna do drugs we all know
that it's part of life but please have
the common courtesy to not steal them
from your dealer
[Music]
I tried the same thing at Sonic once the
guy hung on for three blocks before i
pelted him with a cherry limeade he's
taking food out of an honest drug
dealers mouth but I feel bad for the
white kid because you don't ever want to
drive and have somebody hanging on your
car and them just like look at you like
oh you duh like I've been a criminal for
a long time I still like the white guys
chances in court how old were you the
first time you smoked marijuana 15 more
first 115 did you like it your first
time yes do your peers call you the bong
Lord no no no clue you live with your
parents
yeah you live right under their roof and
they have no idea you're the ball court
no basically living a Doughboy identity
Oh like a superhero yeah why did you
start drinking bong water because it
tastes good it tasted that is disgusting
it's a waste and where's the pond so you
actually get high off the bong water mmm
no - sure - sure kids don't want to
waste any pot yeah that's what the bong
Lord teaches us yes that no pot should
be wasted
none whatsoever
are you stoned right now very yeah
if you were to create your own show what
would you put on it I don't know a
wheelchair boxing fights like the ones
that are on your show probably just
naked chicks party clowns and my mother
[Laughter]
ha Minjae stoners Alaskan halibut baby
girl that'd be pretty crazy wouldn't it
you